at the Bruce and ass
mcwilliams center for
some of the early work is going to be on
simulating the universe on computers
from the Big Bang outward and observing
how the universe is today seeing how
that matches up with how the simulations
show it should work out and we have some
very talented physicist in those areas
and new computers being built to do
those simulations we have a project
we're hoping to get funded that relates
to building a large radio-telescope a
completely new kind of radio telescope
the project has me quite excited because
historically whenever a new kind of
telescope has been introduced that looks
in a different part of the spectrum
we've always discovered things that we
had no idea existed and this is a
completely new kind of instrument and I
feel confident that there will be great
discoveries that will open up new areas
of science
you